same document fragment as before except
we've now added a CSS stylesheet at the
top that renders all paragraph text in
black now consider what happens when we
try to execute our inline JavaScript we
reach into the document and find all the
paragraph tags grab the first one and
set its CSS arm color style to read the
stylesheet says that all paragraphs
should be rendered with black text what
if the CSS stylesheet arrives after the
script is already executed and sets the
color to red with the browser be smart
enough to figure out which color to use
yes it would here's a quick diagram that
illustrates what actually happens the
browser requests the HTML and as soon as
it gets the response it starts building
a Dom it then discovers the CSS and
sends the request then the parse it
continues and finds the script tag at
which point it has to block it doesn't
know what the script is going to do
because the script may want to try
accessing the CSS properties so it
blocks script execution until the CSS
arrives and we build the CSS object
model only then can we run the
JavaScript and then finish building the
Dom wow so CSS blocks rendering and it
blocks JavaScript execution exactly
which is once again why optimizing your
CSS is so important on that note I have
a quick quiz for you